teach him to be brave cuz if I have a
son he's never really say
talking about the song Ruth it's
absolutely beautiful you said when you
originally wrote it you just thinking
it's more of a song for yourself what
was the decisions behind decided to
release it I kind of didn't know if I
wanted to put it out just because it is
super personal and raw I'm gonna quickly
recorded it in my room to try to get my
feelings out but kind of after sharing
it with some of my close family and
friends and seeing their reaction to it
and then kind of like giving the reason
and telling me that it could do some
good that's kind of like help pushing
you just put it out I've never written a
song quite like it or put anything out
like it so it's definitely intimidating
but then the pros outweigh the cons in
terms of like being able to do something
good because even when you
they'll tell you that you are how are
you feeling about everything that's
happening right now where we're at right
now in terms of what the black lives
matter movement is trying to do where
it's that now
I think it's been just unreal to watch
everything unfold but I do I do want to
say that I've been definitely feeling
some sort of sense of hope just by
seeing the unity that's come out of this
I'm in Edmonton Alberta I attended my
first protest a couple weeks ago there's
15,000 people so being able to see that
kind of unity really does give hope and
hope for a better future so I think the
most important thing is people are more
aware people are talking about it people
are seeing the importance in it which is
like the first step but it's it's a big
deal so I think yeah out of out of the
bat and a lot of good has come
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
with the way things are in the world for
black people you're almost hesitant to
have kids as a black person myself I've
faced my share of racism and it's it's
just a scary thing to try to explain to
anyone and so yeah my first time I have
had real conversations about like you
know being afraid for the future and our
kids but yeah I think just in seeing
everything that's happening I I'm
definitely hopeful that things will get
better
[Music]